[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
so far a lot of challenges hundreds of
challenges oh a lot yeah zero winners
zero people have been able to catch us
making a mistake well tonight a couple
of fans with the youtube handle bo
ziffer
think they caught a mistake they claim
it happened during a recent interview
with olivia munn
where i mentioned the penguins of
madagascar
hi conan we were just watching your show
from july 26th
um and while you were
interviewing olivia munn we
noticed a mistake
with all those dancers none of them are
getting gay with each other
well i gotta tell you andy says this
after he sees every movie
oh yeah
you say that about penguins of
madagascar that's ridiculous you call
the penguins of madagascar a movie when
it is actually a nickelodeon tv show an
actual movie that you are thinking of is
madagascar not the penguins of
madagascar
so you are wrong and we really want to
see what you're going to say this time
you went wrong coney you went wrong
mom's got to settle down
it's like kind of a cute video with two
girls and it became a hostage situation
[Music]
these kids shouldn't be watching this
show i know
that's the segment where you're
complaining about there's not enough
we had a problem with that
well i'm sorry you seem very uh nice you
seem adorable but you are wrong bo
ziffer
and intense mom
sure penguins of madagascar is an
animated children's show on nick but it
was originally a movie unfortunately the
movie was only released in europe
because it was considered too complex
for american children
now
it was very hard to do but i actually
got my hands on an imported dvd
of the penguins
of madagascar movie
proof that it's real here's a short clip
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
so take that little girls
[Laughter]
[Applause]
anywho the challenge still stands
okay if you think you've spotted an
error on our show report it at
teamcocoa.com haha i found an error we
will sort it out right here on the air
let's see if you've got what it takes to
make chunk meat out of the maestro